but yeah dude that bombed me boy that
bomb us bro i like it
the civil war is getting mad what else
you got nick
what else we got here this espn fight
pass
[Laughter]
installing your own air conditioner
what's this question one bedroom studio
apartment
install your own air conditioning his
wife is small i'll say that
everything that they showed after you
said ufc fight pass got funnier
like the girl in the costume he's
cracking a beer dude i thought that was
his corner girl man
mike perry from the yeah the new mike
perry training oh my god
new micra training institute yeah
installing your own ac
i like it look you got to stay cold man
anything that gets that cold air in
there
yeah is it installing your own like uh
swamp cooler
i remember when i was a kid my buddy
joey schnegel had a swamp cooler and
that thing was happening dude
was it because we didn't have regular ac
so we just had that swamp cooler
[Music]
i don't know but i remember when we were
like at night mama put the ac down about
two degrees you know so you had to prep
for that [ __ ] you know
so as soon as she cut that [ __ ] down
you had like it was like a time clock
like i better [ __ ] go to sleep right
now
you know while that cold air was flowing
and we would go get some cold water out
of the sink and put it on our bed on
that sheet
and it would just be real cold you know
lay on that sucker bruh because it's hot
out huh yeah just be hot out just in
louisiana just got hot it's hot at night
so i like it man anything you can do to
get that cold air inside you know or
just pretend if you don't do it at least
pretend it's cold
trick the kid you know put ice on the
kid's neck tape ice on its neck
put a little ice pack on the thrift side
yeah put ice pack on
ice pick that in his wrist yeah yeah
it's cold in here and it keep telling
him it's cold yeah
even though he's sweating his balls off
yeah yeah he's like damn this is some
real hot
cold but oh well man
he don't know brian he ain't doing [ __ ]
so he ain't about [ __ ] so
gang bro beautiful little daughter both
those both the kids wearing bees this
time of year i know
bees up he's up when you say bees up
that's a blood thing so
is it yeah dude you almost got a
gangs can't claim everything i can't say
bees up that's true
all right i'll let them have it thanks
doug and there's no more
what are these gangs doing they're
repping their they don't own any real
estate they're always like claiming
these [ __ ] neighborhoods
yeah they don't they're everyone's just
renting yeah everyone's just
if they claim that street you know
[Music]
is